這小哥的對帳單
小哥長期霸凌本主同事的證據
買認售有很大的原因是因為這個節目
嘴巴講那麼多
你有做嗎 小哥你有做嗎
畫線誰不會
對不對 四肉獎誰不會
全正買的巧格天120%
兩天120
存股20年
手上一定要有空單的部位
下跌你也賺錢
上漲你也賺錢
對
全世界台灣人最幸福
都告訴你主力正在賣
主力大獲創高
這種我們叫做
價格籌碼背離
覺得他會有力空的時候
趕快去買認受學證
對 我賭他開法會
今天除夕
怎麼這樣學證怎麼打五折
女優家跟行師比例
忘了改 趕快買
買完之後
再好心地打給發行長
你們好像忘了改了
今天棚內有一個貴客
對啊 我同學
他知道很多你的黑歷史對不對
對啊
高中的時候黑歷史都知道
因為小哥很厲害
小哥高中念熊中
我們高熊的鄉親
我屏東女中的
你屏東女中
對熊中是 我們那時候聯誼
覺得應該很好的對象
好像沒有跟評語連過一樣
對啊
我們都找熊女熊商
然後什麼文藻
對 現在你有機會
現在有機會
就棚內一對一
但是我剛才有問你
不要了
我剛才也問你熊中同學
對小哥的印象在高中
他現在有什麼不同
他就說當時很瘦
對啊 我當時有五十幾公斤
五十幾公斤
對 我隔壁做一個七十公斤
我剛剛怎麼那麼胖啊
七十公斤
我現在覺得七十公斤好瘦喔
那我好榮幸喔
跟現在差好多
對 我認識兩個小哥
對
雙倍小哥
現在應該叫全正大哥
全正隔隔
兩個隔這樣子
對 體重變兩倍
好 但是今天我們要來講的
話題呢 跟體重有一點點關係
因為我們上一集的
哥有籌必報
小哥做了進入股票市場
也來最大的犧牲
就是跟趙華一起量體重
那很多的網友就會問
哥你瘦了嗎
那哥現在是一個
高檔盤整的狀態
那姐呢 好 高檔正當
可能會向下
在盤頭啊
對不對 可是姐
最近有一點主力賣出
所以姐有下跌了1%
即將進入 1%
之後會開布林
開布林
然後快速向下
好 為了迎接
不要太快 不要太快
不要太快嗎
因為你會跟不上是不是
不是啦 我怕那個
萬一之後有什麼狀況
嗯
我們還是要
你看大陸啊
我們很想大陸大陸
大陸那邊有風塵嘛
對
台灣還好 台灣目前不會
大陸那邊有風塵
你看只要胖的人
他可以活比較久
哎呦
是不是
小哥現在在為這個
消耗久一點
小哥在為他不想
他應該不會這樣
不想開不臨往下
這件事情來做預防針
台灣不會啦 台灣很安全
但是最近的氣氛真的是讓人家覺得
比較恐怖一點
對 然後趙華提中也希望可以往空方邁進
所以今天的重點在什麼
今天我們要來教大家
怎麼愛的破將賺大錢
好 愛的破將
愛的破將賺大錢
來 請問一下
你有沒有看過這部片啊
我用 我跟你講你不看都不行
因為會有無數的人貼他的劇情
在你的臉書上面 對
我們沒時間看啦
晚上都在看重把黑線
真的喔 那我們等一下來演一下好不好
我們這一集的封面不一樣
我演底下這個
你演底下這個嗎
我演這個嗎
你還不然來錄節目
我們看老婆還不然來錄節目
好 所以演誰都不行
由都不能來了
所以這個愛的破將很棒
愛的破將是講說
有人不小心飄到北韓
飄到北韓
認識一個帥哥
對 然後認識一個大帥哥
但是我們這邊看到一個
小哥長期霸凌本主統治的證據
這是貼證據 貼證據給你看
就是我們有在做交易
就像你會貼
在FB上面貼你的菜單一樣
你不是貼300道菜嗎
對啊
對啊 我說你應該去主持那個
故意挑晚餐時間破
都霸凌大家的胃
對啊 你看我們錄這種節目
都要準備一堆東西
對
下次還錄那美食節目就好
喔 沒問題
我除一張嘴就好
對啊 這樣比較輕鬆
你除一張嘴就是吃嘛
這樣體重很難下去
就吃就好了
不然就這個準備那麼多
小哥的愛的破將大家可以看一下
這是小哥的對帳單
以前我沒有認識小哥的時候
我覺得小哥好神喔
每天都貼那個對帳單
可是後來認識小哥之後
就覺得這是一種愛的霸凌
為什麼
因為每次看到小哥一直賺啊
一直賺啊 本主同仁
因為我賠錢的時候啦
只是最近剛好那個
攤名抓得不錯
最近都沒有看到而已啦
最近多空都有賺喔
所以這是小哥的 這是國劇的
認售權證
大家會教各位啊
這國劇為什麼買了這個點
對 買的那個點買得很漂亮
對 而且沒有叫我們一起買
因為那個也有點賭一把的味道
因為那隔天的波動一定會很大
也受限於金管會的法規本金
是符合法規的節目
對 讓你看結果就好
好 不能提早講
對 然後我們上次呢
你有考了三個隨堂考
今天要來公佈答案
對 我們現在回顧一下
先讓大家好不好
做做功課 複習一下
除息後的股價會因為配股後
配息而修正
那因為全正跟著限股跑嘛
所以認售全正不就穩賺嗎
去買認售啊 股價修正啦
這個存償好之前我先考造華
請問一下100塊的股票配息20塊
隔天平盤價變多少
80太厲害了
第二個問題
100塊的股票配股10塊
配股10塊隔天平盤價變多少
配股喔 剛剛是配股
因為我買過配10
就是配10塊股票的
反正是最聰明的財經主持人
我不能公布是哪一檔
因為大家回去回說
就知道我是哪一年買股票
欸 該不會傳奇
配10塊 常看到傳奇配10塊
好 來看一下
這個除夕號因為配股配股
股價會下降
那股價會下降呢
有人講說
現在下降買認售不就穩賺了嗎
我覺得他這個網友很聰明啊
很聰明喔
他想要抓權正的bug
對 抓權正漏洞
那這個漏洞發行商早就知道啦
也對齁
對啊 他怎麼可能讓你那麼好賺
所以呢 他呢 他早就知道
所以他在除權洗的前一天
前一晚
是
他們就會把這個旅約價
還有行私比例
全部都
這兩個呢 做修正
再跟你講喔
以前的bug還有什麼bug
以前這buck很常出現
就是做多的
做多認購權正
在除席的那一天
他的履業家跟刑事比例忘了改了
放棄改了
對他前一天可能賣一塊
那因為隔天股價變低
他忘了改
還有這回事
忘了改隔天權正一開版剩五毛
所以小哥有抓到過
有預望
怎麼今天除席
怎麼這樣權正怎麼打五折
趕快買
買完之後再好心地打給發行商
你們好像忘了改囉
不是 因為他忘了給他
他還要再把他調回來
他才賺的啦
對 他要調回來
謝謝你 我們也把它改回來
你看 以前用這一招
還賺了一點點你用錢啦
是不是 所以各位玩友們
發現小哥在霸凌我們
小哥他以前都有賺到這種bug
現在沒有囉
現在沒有這種bug了
好吧 所以打一個是
因為我們bug一次
那個發行商會賠很多
所以現在沒有這種bug了
所以這個就是不會穩賺
不會穩賺
因為發行商已經把現在行事比例
那些都改回來了
所以儲全息就是正常的
好不好 正常的
好 來 第二個問題
第二個問題
還記得我們上次講台積電
對 台積電的維買賣變化
全正的維買賣加9.8
變化非常大 對
那有人就說全正又不能當充
當然全正是不能當充的 是
所以當你全正有庫存的時候
你才能做先買後賣
賣的舉動
或先賣後買都可以
因為你有庫存
他跟以前我們還沒有開放
線股當中的股票是一樣的
你要有庫存才有辦法
當天買賣
那全證成交量重不重要
我跟你講成交量這個東西
一直都很重要
你做什麼型態 技術分析
價量都很重要
所以我覺得重要
好 你覺得重要
那我跟你講很多市面上
很多書啊 很多網站
都跟你講全證成交量很重要
我懂了 正確答案是
那些書要去電湯
電火鍋
那一書根本是亂寫
又是亂寫的
對 陳教亮一點都不重要
老闆公布答案
我覺得有點太誇張了
陳教亮一點都不重要
為什麼 非常不重要
為什麼
因為這個發行商會造勢
這跟ETF一樣
你要賣 你不用怕
發行商會掛買架出來
你要買呢 你也不用擔心
換一商會掛賣家出來
所以你跟股員其實某種程度是好朋友
這樣子啊
對 因為他在推ETF
很多人都說
ETF成交量流動性很低 他還敢推
他就覺得
因為他換一商會造勢
對 他就說會造勢
造勢就不用擔心
所以全證也是同樣的
因為有券商發行這個商品
對
那其實我們在玩出全息的時候
除非洗這個買全證
都是希望明天股票會跳空開高
對啊
因為除非洗的時候 這個
例如說他今天配10塊錢
100塊配10塊
隔天是不是剩90
那有的每天掛單
每天他說我每天就掛95塊買進
95塊買進 95塊買進
他忘了今天儲錢洗
他也掛95塊買進
所以隔天莫名其妙開高
就是因為有這種人
他忘了儲錢洗了
不會有一些股票也很強勢
像什麼台積電
他可能當天就填一半
只當天填一半
那這個其實跟那個掛的人
有的會有一些關係
所以呢我們出演戲都是前天買好
隔天跳空開高
趕快賣全正
所以呢我玩出演戲的時候
巴不得
只有你這樣玩
只有我在玩
只有你在玩量也很大好不好
呵呵
只有我在玩
那至少開心
我不用跟別人搶著那邊排啊對不對
那個賣全正跟排隊買口罩一樣
還要排隊
對
那假如成交用大
你就會遇到這種問題
沒問題
假如只有你玩
就沒有這種問題啦
現在口罩量有放大了
有放大
對 給政府一個鼓勵這樣子
對 可以買三片了
可以買三片了
還不錯
對 好
那最近這個大盤下跌
有的人
這個群組有些人
這跟巧克講
還好有跟到小哥
為什麼 因為我們長期都會跟
這個學生講說
你手上一定要有空單的部位
這個我深深有體會
對
下跌你也賺錢
上漲你也賺錢
所以我們永遠都在看小哥賺錢
也是我有朋友是吧
那個空南部位呢 有的人講
那空南部位 那我就去找台子
這放空的啊
那丟檔 有工具 來 反向ETF
00632啊 這叫什麼名字
就是俗稱的T50反
T50反嘛 對
那雖然它的標的不是T50啊
並不是 並不是
但是它名字叫T50反
我是覺得這名字很奇怪 對
為什麼呢 因為你要去找做空的
你還去找全台灣前50名
是不是 等著變
沒有台灣價值
沒有國家設計的概念
你怎麼可以這樣子
那個前50名是怎樣
是他變弱一點點
立馬在淘汰
再換一個更強的上來
你知道嗎
他會有替換的
會有替換的
你怎麼可以去挑前50名來打呢
要踹但是踹落水狗啊
不動了
就像我不應該跟
我不能跟小哥對做
我要跟俞成對做
他才60幾公斤
對做是看體重的
對
所以那個這個T50
我覺得他名字就取得很奇怪
不過如果看理財單元秀
不管你看哪一個單元
是看歌友仇必報
還是看成股底報
你還去買T50
反就代表你沒有好好看
好不好
因為我們常常講
這檔並不適合做空
這個假設我發行
我要發行那個台灣B50
為什麼是B呢
台灣最爛的50
最背的50檔
最背的50檔我放空它
不錯喔
你發這種ETF
大家才想買嘛
是不是
靠最爛的來空
好思維好思維
對啊這是T50
第二個006771
這個我還真沒研究
這是什麼
富邦VIX
富邦VIX 這個嗎
富邦VIX 這個很多人
為什麼這個台股大碟富邦VIX沒碟
常有的事
因為這檔已經黑歷史了
它根本不是跟台股有關
它這跟那個
那個恐慌指數有關
跟VIX指數
美國的恐慌指數
可是VIX指數跟它
好像也不是那麼連動
一堆人去買他買到怎麼樣你知道嗎
買到溢價好幾%
我曾經看網路30%
溢價30% 有的人還去放空他
不過最近放空他可能會被小高一點
因為最近每一股波都太大
是
是這樣子
所以這兩個看起來都不愛
說真的啦 這兩檔
我們之前也告訴過大家
其中的貓膩就是不要
對對對對對
就不要隨便把他當作放空的標的
這樣子
小哥再來幫我們背書了
再買就打屁股了
這不會來找你們嘛
我不確定
好 那第二個呢
放空線股
下跌賺錢放空線股
很正常啊
對 放空線股可以啦
放空線股是叫龍券放空
不過很多人都不曉得什麼是要放空
為什麼
所以待會我們再講詳細一點
好 那放空線股呢
假如你的資金這個比較少
你也可以空
放空股票期貨
比較期貨 槓桿很大
槓桿大概7倍
4到7倍
對
那或者是你買認售權證
小哥的專長
小資主買認受權政最好
可是這個我也怕
也怕喔 其實就是手腳塊
手腳塊
抓好時間點 是
今天給各位看
這個我的造型
所以小哥非常靈活
很靈活 對
小哥是我們權政界的紅金寶
對 下次來錄一段那個去打籃球
好 沒問題
那什麼叫放空野賺錢
這個 因為很多人都會問
做多很簡單很容易理解
買10塊賣12塊就賺2塊啊
這大家都會
就正思考啊
不用逆思考啊
那股票也可以做空啊
你可以把你的方向呢
反過來
對
你原本是買10塊賣12塊
你先做賣12塊
對
先賣12塊
之後等到跌到10塊
你再買回來
對
那這樣也是賺2塊
你知道什麼難嗎
對
因為減肥難
增肥比較簡單
是這樣子
對 長高簡單你要再變矮
我深深覺的
對啊 我的體重呢
從我結婚之後
每年固定一公斤上揚
對不對
對啊 但是錄完我們的歌有仇必報
你要收十公斤 不要忘記喔
希望可以啊 講不下去
好 那介紹這個各種放空工具的特色
對 這有些放空
放空沒錢 那我們來玩線骨
當充好了 鮮脈再買
這個是風險超大
這超級大 無極大
這個難道沒有比權正好嗎
我也是當天無本生意啊
沒有 先賣賺也對
我都不用交歌 我就
有人一直在教無本當中
無本當中很
大家如果看我們頻道
YouTube也出現無本當中的廣告
不要拜託你不要點進去
不要相信好不好
真的會有問題
當充成本最高
什麼叫無本當中
當充成本超高的
請他們不要下載
我們李財達社頻道
看了很歪腰這樣
對 歪腰
對 當充成本高
你不要相信無本
當充的這個我們算成本
交易稅1.5
首續被這個1.8
來回多少
1.4
1.4點多
你當充個250次
250次之後你的本都沒了
250次之後交易你就跟你交往
對啊他可能喜歡你
不過他應該不會愛上你
因為他知道你的對象大概很醜
他知道你沒有前途
就遲到把錢賠光
當中它是這個成本高
好 成本太高了
風險很大
而且先賣再買
其實在台灣
在台灣做空的人是比較沒人權
沒人權
對 常常要回補嘛
問你一個問題
你有聽過放空貝嘎成立製救會嗎
沒聽過嘛
怎麼可以
都是做都被
做都被坑然後成立製救會
被坑殺才要製救啊
貝嘎就是我判斷錯誤
分字就會
對
貝卡叫細赫
所以叫你去空別股票
對不對 你不看好別人
對 你不看好別人
人家貝卡細赫
都是你這樣亂來
所以呢 放空的人在台灣
怎麼沒有人權
沒有人權
可是我們等一下要教的是
認受權證
認受就還好
就比較有人權嗎
風險比較小一點
哎呦
好 會比較小一點
那小新的漲停沒眷流腸
這個最恐怖
我常常聽到小哥在那邊吊卷
對 只要沒有眷流腸
每天一早都要跟營業員先調捲
要空的話
對
這個假如沒見流倉
就要標戒費
很恐怖喔
標戒費很恐怖
一天7%
對喔 一天7%
而且隔天是漲停板幫你補回來
真的
對啊
例如說你今天放空平盤
對
這個1萬塊
搭到漲停
對
先賠1000
10%嘛
對
隔天再收你7%標戒費
那就是17%
再收你700
700而已喔
還沒完
隔天有可能是
讓你漲停去回補
那漲停回補可能還補不到
然後只要補到的話再賠10%
所以你空平盤有可能賠掉27%
這個標介費可能大家要特別留意
這個很恐怖
所以這個放空門都要講
你要最小心這個標介費
那借券呢
你要額外負擔借券利息
這就是交官在賺的啊
股越在賺這個啊
全部的人都在做
長期投資
對啊 那因為有些人他喜歡這個做空
他這個沒有龍券他就去借券
那其實借券放空也有些特色
對
這個在三四月份的時候
其實可以用借券來玩套利
哎呦
也不知道
不知道
我們下一次再講
以後再講
因為那個要花比較多時間
我們請古瑜來跟你PK
他在講券怎麼借給你把利息借高
你在講我如何借券
借你的借來空員給我套利
好好好
好下一集來測話
下集來測話
我要給他PK一場
對
好
第四個
第五個買認售權證
對
反正這個時間價值容易流失
喔對啊
你就說過了嘛
對 那時間價值容易流失
你們就要挑好時間點
好
那第六個呢
股票期貨放空
對
那這個剛很大喔
要注意流動性的問題
對 但是這個小哥也滿喜歡的
也許我們再找一集來講
對 好
那標戒費我們大概提一下
好 到底多貴 標戒費
可能大家都跟趙華一樣不曉得
我們放空還有標戒費
產生的可能性
你看這個線股當中每一卷
你就必須跟投資人標戒股票
3.5%到7% 7%
有的卷商是直接收7%
對 他就沒有3.5% 這很恐怖
那個龍劍放空流倉
這個每天有驚訝
因為他的標戒費
每天不知道多少錢
很恐怖
剛剛才接到這個電話而已
那這個反過來
有股票的人可以去眷商那邊填寫費
可以看到表姐
反正我長一投資嘛
假如有人要借我的眷
你就借給他
那有時候一天就賺個兩三趴
也不錯
那我們複習
我們今天重頭戲的講
認受全證
就是所有的放空工具裡面
其實小哥覺得認受全證
是小資主罪能適合來用的
因為他不用花很多錢
那麼看 認受權政就是股票下跌
他會上漲
他就漲
股票下跌會上漲
很簡單的原理
很簡單
認受權政一樣就是唱衰個股
唱衰個股
一樣唱衰個股
那你要跳時間點
那認受權政做空的優點
對 為什麼這一集對不對
那麼多標的
我們都這不好那不好
為什麼認受權政
小哥覺得相對好
我們要講一些風險給人家
大家投資人才不會遇到這些
因為你不想跟大家一起玩嘛
你剛剛也有講
你只想自己玩
我們在出來這個
錄節目是做功德的
是真的
因為怕很多投資人
不曉得這些商品
有什麼樣的風險
那因為這些風險
我們都承受過了
是
都賠過了
上個會我都會講說
你看這一檔我怎樣賠
因為什麼原因賠
這些都賠過了 很有經驗
所以跟高中比起來
也現在多杯了30公斤的風險
對 壓力壓力
這個胖士氣跟壓力很有很大關係
對啊 有一天不做國票可能就瘦下來
來 請問做空的優點
一個人不怕被標減
可是標減會很恐怖
第二個不用強制回補
這很重要呢
最近股東會出演習一堆回補
最近股東會
股東會前兩個月很多要回補了
那嘴息像達爾夫
達爾夫要出席
差不多要除息了
3月就除息
你看很多強制回補的
第三損失有限
因為你買的金額不大
這個股票放空很恐怖
你有可能拿100塊去放空
賠了300塊
對 有可能overlose
全證是不會
就是賠光
第四個容易買到想要的部位
怎麼說呢
因為你要融券放空
有的券沒幾張
他比較不會有接不到卷那樣的一個窘定
對 所以部位就可以比較容易的放放
因為你剛剛有講 成交量他沒有那麼重要
對 因為發行商你要買他造勢給你
對 他造勢給你
好 所以比較容易買到喔
對 好 來看這個
但是認受權證要怎麼進場
怎麼進場 對不對
小哥好不好 用必生功力告訴你
四個進場訊號 四個這樣一點
第一個寬布林
寬布林 來問一下造法
叫寬布林
寬布林就是小哥的腰圍
腰圍 對 就是
袋寬
布林通到袋寬20%以上
反正是20% 很聰明
袋寬就是局來說
通到底100塊
通到頂120
那袋寬就是20%啦
20%
寬布林 然後他骨架在上軌
骨架碰上軌
這個剛剛其實我看到有一點疑問
碰喔 不是站喔
不是站上上軌
你碰你可能是骨架
然後碰到上面 剛碰到
那不是站在上面
在上面讓上軌很敲那不行喔
可是骨架如果碰上軌
有沒有可能他正在漲呢
他假如是你要看那個上軌的斜率
上軌斜率很抖的不能空
不能空
有上軌斜率本來就平了
可以
上軌斜率是往下跌的
更好
原來如此
所以你就看那個上通道
是漲什麼樣子
對
你記得很抖的不要去空
對因為我們去看布林通道
他有通道是平的
有的是甚至往下彎
還開布林
那個就最好
沒錯
好
寬布林碰上軌
第二個主力籌碼
要站在賣房
好 主力籌碼出現了
哇 這個很多人來問
很多國外的來喔
國外嗎
對啊 小哥這個
我好想上你的課喔
你想上我的課 可以啊 歡迎啊
可是我住溫哥華怎麼辦
溫哥華那我去找你玩
你不用來
好 這個
另外一個說
小哥那個我在馬來西亞
請問一下
主力籌碼的英文叫什麼
叫什麼
主力籌碼英文
我們的製作人是外電編
外電編
好 叫什麼
這個沒有
沒有
他沒有公佈啊
沒有啊
沒公佈啦
全世界台灣人最幸福啊
對
都告訴你主力正在賣啊
其他股票都沒跟你講的啊
所以台灣的籌碼是最透明的
台灣最透明
台灣最好啊
對啊台灣連口罩幾個都跟你講
是不是
因為手機都划得到
對 口罩地圖
對啊
而且越來越Match現況
剛開始還說不Match現況
現在都很Match現況
對
這個主力籌碼都告訴你說
這間誰賣的賣幾張
都告訴你
哇
不是台灣人做股票很辛苦
台灣人做股票你沒賺錢
不要學做海棋
海棋都沒告訴你怎麼辦
更黑對不對
對啊 好
第三個呢
這個有股東會或法說會時
導致波動的消息
上一集有教
那個是利多的時候
趕快去賭他隔天會噴出
去買認購權證
但今天這個反過來
反過來
覺得他會有利空的時候
趕快去買認受權證
我賭他開法會
開法會 不是法說會
不是太晚了 我賭他的股東會被嗆聲
被嗆聲
我賭他的股東會被外資降頻
喔唷
對啊 因為股東會他必須跟股東報告
說我們要做什麼事情
外資說你這個降頻
你賭他股東會早上6點就開
不希望大家來
對 有這樣的公司耶
有戰功
好壞
好 第四個關鍵分點先賣
然後今天送各位一個
我知道趙瓦的意思
可是講到關鍵分點
小哥就是不肯說
好 今天特別送一檔
所以股民也希望你不要講
等一下小哥會送一個禮物
跟關鍵分店有關係
看下去看下去
來來來 我們現在看國具
為什麼我會去空國具
為什麼我去買國具的認售
這個絕對不能用感情用事
不行 你不能說我看他不爽
有的人說我這裡看他不爽
一直空空空空空 跌下來也是沒賺
可多了
可多 不行不行
所以檔就是有點你知道
像輔和小哥講的腰嘛
對 你不能看他不爽
空最寄會看他不爽
情緒行動
對
你必須要找好的時間點
好的時間點是
可是前期動已經走了
前期他前年
也沒有新老婆啊
沒新老婆
有有
今年他改完一個
哎呦
改完一個
待會跟你講
改完一個這個
財務操作啦
不要亂來
不是玩藝人
好好好
哎呦
我在照著被告
沒有
他沒有玩那個
好
這個玩股票玩得好
他根本連去玩那個興趣都沒有
哎呦
充分滿足
充分滿足 來
來看一下國際
為什麼在這段下跌你知道嗎
這段下跌應該是
突然下跌的
我記得是
對動員間沒有缺貨
不是 不是
這是回國於基本面的想法
對 基本面前嘛 沒有
他不會說突然沒缺貨
突然又缺貨
不會這樣嘛
他就是這樣嘛
好 突然下跌是有原因的
怎麼說呢
好 帶來這跟念寶園
好 那我們再回來看這邊
這裡有兩個地方
這裡 它在這邊股價往上漲的時候
我們來看這裡
這裡有主力買賣鈔
其實長期而言
主力是在加空的
對耶
主力在買嘛
一對人看他不爽去放空
主力加散物空
但是到了這兩個點
最後這兩根紅K
主力在出貨囉
紅K反而在出貨
紅K出貨 散戶受不了 散戶進去追了
因為在這邊新聞很多啊
都是利多
都利多
不用一天缺貨嘛
漲價嘛
散戶受不了 進去追了
主力到貨了
而且看起來股價就是一直往上創高
創高 主力到貨
主力到貨創高
這種我們叫做價格
籌碼背離了
價格籌碼背離
對 價格籌碼背離
這是我第一個想空的點
價格籌碼背離
如果說今天價格創高
籌碼他繼續買就沒有什麼空點
可是還會漲
對 沒錯
可是價格創高 籌碼已經在出囉
對
這已經產生了第一個理由
那這個主力要賣幾天
你才會覺得是
這個賣個兩天我就覺得差不多了
就覺得差不多了
因為這個第一個他蠻高檔的
其實我也看他不爽
不是 我要長個十年
我要長個好時間點進場
你不能說開不早隨時進場
那會出問題啦
要找個時間點進場
所以第一個理由出現了
好 看他病要他命
對 第二個理由
我在觀察前波為什麼下跌
對 為什麼
前波下跌是因為國際要發行GDR
喔 玩外國的
對 要發行GDR
不玩本國的了
發行GDR呢 這樣下跌
下跌呢
這次呢這跟大黑K的當天
他開股東會
開臨時股東會
前波董事會說要發
臨時股東會說我要確認要發
要讓股東通過
所以看來股東是對這個決議
是害怕的
股東通過了
股東是通過 但小股民
小股民這個主力稱之為到貨
外資也覺得這個發GDR不太好
內行人知道發GDR是個警訊
對 所以我們又有第二個空的理由
我們都會講 你必須要多找幾個理由
對啊
你找這個 沒有多找幾個理由
你去做股票 你無法說服你自己
因為相愛的理由要千百種
分手的理由只有一種
哪一個
就是沒有感覺
我還以為是沒有教堂
所以才沒有感覺
沒有感覺
我還會想同一個東西
是不是理財節目
就越講訓節目了
你看上次1月11號
歷史都在重演
GDR外資下到衝擊股價
周錯16%
外資其實不喜歡他去發GDR
缺點會扣大股本
股本膨脹18.6%
股本膨脹當然會稀釋獲利
就會影響股東權益
所以他短線是個利空
所以小股民沒感覺
外資感覺很多
他們就會去這個降頻
所以呢我們找兩個理由之後
我們就要買全證啦
好 來吧 我們就要來
全證我只花兩天喔
我是26號買 27號出
26號再開股東會的時候
我就進去買
你的愛好短喔
我們玩全證就這麼短
我們愛的破將真的是
就這麼短
因為你全證跟他長相失手
沒意思啦
對
玩短一點
你各位看一下我買99張
我按都一次按99
9個張
陳交金的1塊錢
這是賣出的價格
買進金的44614
4萬多塊而已
所以這個價格
大概是0.44買的
所以你看我0.44買
0.43買
0.44買
我在這邊買
我都賣0.89 1塊錢
0.83 0.8 1.8 2
都是倍數在賺
對
因為你買的買的很漂亮
那最高的報酬率有121%
全正買的橋隔天120%
兩天120
存股20年
差不多20年
一年6%大概20年
所以你要挑時間
你講沒有挑時間
可能隔天就賠個10% 20%
所以挑時間去買
其實獲利就不錯
所以愛上認受全正的理由
要有好幾種
分手只有一種就不夠長
不要把它解決掉
什麼東西
不能放太長
沒感覺
這麼刺激
那除了這個理由以外
其實我還有第三個理由
第三個理由
因為國劇跟華興科
都屬於被動元件
沒錯 同產業
那被動元件呢
他在227塊的時候
在這個點
227塊的時候
有個關鍵分點
大賣多少張
大賣1000多張
哇塞 這個很醒目耶
1000多張耶
誰有1000多張的華辛科啊
誰
關鍵分點誰
一定是跟老闆有很大的關係
才有1000多張嘛
不然誰有信心
買1000多張華辛科
1000多張華辛科多少錢啊
2億多
2億多呢
2億多一天就砍掉了
對啊
2億多一天砍掉
你看砍完之後股價還往上漲
股價沒有馬上跌
所以是小股東又去接了
對 這個因為這邊
國際的新聞很漂亮
國際就在上漲
所以大家覺得聯動啊
聯動嘛 都是被動元件啊
好 那時候我看他
這麼厲害的人都賣227了
我230我也可以賣啊
240我也可以賣
你賣得比他還漂亮
最高有到256啊
256 那240
這個價格你賣的其實都怎麼樣
都賣得比這個
關鍵人物還來得厲害
人家多張啦
需要早點把它賣掉
沒有
後來 接下來就怎麼樣
股價告訴這個人說
幹得好
賣得漂亮
他已經告訴你
他早就知道了
早就知道之後會跌
很多股票是這樣
賣完之後過沒多久
就會跟這個主力講
賣得很漂亮
那這個主力是誰呢
是誰
是誰又回到話題
我們這是特別
哎呦哎呦哎呦
這個加入小哥的Telegram
不用錢不用錢
Telegram你好潮哦
對 我們現在Telegram
1萬多人哦
哇Telegram哇
1萬多人比我們東正新聞還多耶
對
然後那我可以導流一下
加入小哥的Telegram
在節目播出的當天
我就告訴你
現實公開分點名稱
這一個嗎
就這個分點
那你現在為什麼不講
就這個而已
你為什麼不跟我講
嗯嗯嗯
為什麼不跟我講
為什麼小哥在自己Telegram講
不在理財達人秀講
那個 刀割流吧
沒關係啦
大家趕快加入小哥的Terrugin好不好
因為小哥是我們的好朋友
其實很多人會覺得
來上理財達人秀啊
真的不是你們想要那麼簡單
因為他們都會把一些
本來要收費的課程
都在這一堂課講完
真的
所以小哥必須留一點
到他的Terrugin
那我們也贊成好不好
大家趕快加入
好 感謝
超越我們的蔡英文總統
不敢 不敢 不敢
好 這
那我除了買認售
其實買認售有很大的原因
是因為這個節目
怎麼說呢
為了要做節目嗎
要做節目
因為你講一堆認售
嘴巴講那麼多
你有做嗎 小哥你有做嗎
你有做嗎
你每次都找那個
事後來畫線給我們看
對啊
你有做嗎
是不是
很多投資人說
畫線誰不會
對不對 事後講誰不會
所以我們就要事前做
誰敢這樣嗆啊
事前
很多人都會這樣講
所以我們都
很自然的就聽說
就真的有做嘛
對 所以哥現在有籌幣報嘛對不對
誰敢追我
對 就是給你看
那你看華興科
你看有答我們就上次講的
他有關鍵分點賣
我做97口賺22萬
那華興科呢
這也是有關鍵分點賣
做21口就賺100萬
這個
一口大概賺了5萬塊
5萬塊就是大概是25塊
因為他一口是2000張
2000張
那國際呢這13口賺95
這也是賺得還不錯
這大概一口可以賺到七萬多
七萬多大概四十幾塊
重點是後面起交稅
你有沒有發現起交稅超便宜
超低的
股票期貨交稅超便宜
你只要用龍券放空
這交稅超貴
小哥一天可以做一百多口
而且只是部分
部分
那天的那個
超大戶
最近運氣不錯
所以待會請各位吃點東西
想破壞我們的減重計畫就對了
我怕我們兩個體重拉開了
待會我的份給你吃
不行不行不行
你吃兩份雞排兩個真奶
真奶是不是
好
所以這個交易是很便宜
所以可以用股票期盤來做
好
那這個以後
騎交所也是我們好朋友
有空我們再交這個
好多多交易期貨
學會對的交易方式之後
來稍微嘗試交易期貨
期貨也是一個好的工具
你騎你把它分散
其實期貨很安全
對 而且我們騎交所的稅
對不對
收得不多
10萬分之二呢 是不是
千分之三 10萬分之二
來回他是來回都要收
所以你做一組下來差75倍
75倍 你準備資金又不用那麼多
跟你玩的人也比較少
對 我的人比較少
好 那認購跟認售比較
來個大總結 紮大總結
這個我們製作認售
認售是做空的
上檔是有限的
因為股票下跌是有限的
來槓桿比較小
照式季度比較差一點
發音上比較不完
沒人權的概念
對啊 可是有的話就好好買
那插槓筆0.5%以下就很好了
插槓筆大家回去複習
像全證第一集有講插槓筆
認購要0.3以下
對 因為認購條件比較好
認售比較差
那全證總數認售就比較少
比較少也符合你講的
其實我們就比較不會有選擇障礙
沒錯 對啊
好
那這個我們最後呢
為什麼緩緩的拿出一張
給各位看結論
結論
我們來製作結論
來 第一個全正買得早
不如買得巧
全正買得巧
不如多聽小哥的課
才能買得巧
謝謝 感謝
第二個 近期波動大增
對 暴漲暴跌的盤越來越迷路
你知道川普在2015年
講了什麼話嗎
我知道
他說每股跌1000點的話
這總統應該把它射到
怎麼 不知道射到太陽系去
裝到加農泡射出去
射到太陽系他今年被射兩次
對 就要回來啦
他射去之後人家把它射回來
他就射回來
所以波動大增
全正值得好好研究
你就可以買全正來參與這個波動
是
那這時候全正倉比找0.5%以下的
叉鋼筆可以回去複習好不好
忘記的話
那小時候不知道行情什麼時候發動
我覺得他會跌 他會跌
但我不知道什麼時候
對
那你要買加那一點的
好 那要知道它什麼時候發動
今天開法會 開法會
我今天就買 明天就有行情了
那種呢 你就可以找槓桿大的
當然大家就比較多是加外
比較多加外 對
好 那我們決定是這樣
聽完這個我們要不要去試試看
去練習買一張韌獸來試試看
然後來嗆小哥
看小哥講的對不對
一張很便宜啊
0.45 450塊
對 很便宜
好 對
所以我們今天的歌有仇必報
小哥他剛剛講了
他是為了來錄我們的理財大任秀
特地去做認受權證
因為他要證明認受就是
他的風險相對並沒有那麼大
可是卻容易賺到錢
那我們今天比較非常多做空的工具
另外一個就是小哥也覺得說
如果用期貨來做空
期貨指數來做空
也是一個好的工具
那我們之後如果大家有興趣的話
我們請小哥再來幫我們講
好 那我們今天的歌有時不需要
就到這邊了
有問題的話留言給我們喔
我們拜拜囉
掰掰
先一段完
記得啦
可是小哥很快耶
我們現在在進行減重比賽喔
小哥知道我減了三排功課之後
就決定買這些起司
好不好
然後這是小哥的高中科學
隨便你買
迷客下
請大家支持一下好不好
六周業內好喝
高中學開的
對
農安店
然後這什麼
這是昭華最喜歡的
立法院雞排
老闆就是我
吃這個可以鹹肥你知道嗎
為什麼
一天你就只能吃一份雞排內的蒸奶
那都不要吃了
那就鹹肥了
蛤
怎麼歪理
因為它熱量還是不夠
所以想說老婆
她晚上晚上不可以給她吃
對 晚上不是了
她雞排跟蒸奶有沒有可以
套後果的口水跟醉
套什麼理論
多高有
欸
對 多高有啊
你不能說一只喝蒸奶
一直做多
那是吃雞排一直放空不行
多空到一邊
我懂了
所以大盤多合小哥就會拿出雞排
好 雞排 你看看我雞排
多空到一邊 不是綠的時候就會拿出米特下
你看看
兩邊都賺錢
好啦 謝謝小哥請我們
好啦 同志的理財單
就有什麼必報的
節目主持雞排
然後乾杯啦
好 乾杯 來
好 繼續來